[Musique]
au Sénégal les vastes forêts de
Casamance s'étendent sur des milliers
d'hectares
la région est surnommée le poumon vert
du pays
[Musique]
d'arbre rare comme le bois de rose le
Kyle cédrat ou le poirier du Cayor
mais ces dernières années un vaste
trafic décime des parcelles entières de
forêt
[Musique]
avant on pouvait même pas rentrer ici
tellement c'était étouffe maintenant il
n'y a plus de feuillage plus d'arbustes
pour nourrir notre bétail
chaque année l'équivalent de trois fois
la superficie de Paris serait abattu
illégalement dans ses forêts
les bois précieux passent
clandestinement en Gambie voisine
le Sénégal a formellement interdit de
couper du bois dans ses forêts
mais cette loi est loin d'être respectée
[Musique]
alors des militants écologistes
patrouilles
[Musique]
ne peuvent pas contrôler ses forêts
parce que c'est des hectares et des
hectares forêts là où l'État échoue nous
nous pouvons réussir on s'enfonçant dans
la brousse
dicoribaldé découvre ce campement
clandestin
ouais ça c'est les sonos qui sont passés
par là donc comme ceci c'est franchement
coupé
un peu plus loin
le son des tronçonneuses
les coupeurs de bois sont là à une
centaine de mètres
[Musique]
mieux vaut rester à distance
ils sont plus forts
qu'est-ce que vous pensez parce que
c'est leur gagne-pain ils sont prêts à
tout pour se défendre la marchandise est
exportée par bateau vers la Chine pour
être transformé en meuble de luxe et il
faut dire que ce business est lucratif
rien que pour l'espèce la plus prisée le
bois de rose les exportations depuis la
Gambie s'élèvent à 280 millions d'euros
en 6 ans
impactant largement capté en Casamance
par un groupe indépendantiste armé lié à
ce trafic depuis le début de l'année les
accrochages entre coupeurs de bois
clandestins et autorité ont déjà fait 6
morts
pas de quoi décourager ce trafiquant qui
souhaite rester anonyme
on sait bien qu'on est en train de tuer
la forêt mais on n'a pas de travail on
peut faire que ça pour survivre
le problème c'est que passer en Gambie
est un jeu d'enfants la frontière
délimitée par de simples pierres et très
peu surveillés et vous voyez les déposer
Lego qui sont installés tout prêt à 100
mètres du Sénégal au moins 12 dépôts
comme celui-ci ont été identifiés en
Gambie juste de l'autre côté de la
frontière
le pays réussi l'exploit de faire partie
des cinq plus grands exportateurs
mondiaux de bois de rose alors qu'il n'a
quasiment plus de forêt tout le monde
voit le Wake mais personne ne fait rien
ça nous fait mal que
du bois au Sénégal la corruption si au
niveau des services habilités à ce
trafic c'est eux qu'on paye c'est eux
qui laissent le bois en train la plus
grande partie de ce problème c'est la
corruption c'est la corruption
les autorités sénégalaises démontent et
pointe la complicité des habitants avec
les trafiquants il va falloir que ces
populations locales également puissent
aider dans la détection et dans dans la
traque de ces trafic de ce trafic là
chaque année environ 100000 tonnes de
bois de rose sont exportés de Gambie
rien ne semble arrêter la destruction
des dernières forêts du Sénégal